mother's day is sunday and if you
haven't gotten you something for mom yet
you better do it soon because you know
we're running out of time flowers of
course are always a really popular
option but a late purchase could leave
you empty-handed jeremy ford tells us
how inflation is certainly affecting our
local floral industry
with mother's day on the horizon some
floral companies are facing post
pandemic challenges in preparation for
sunday i have been in this industry all
my life i have never seen inflation
affect flowers the way the pandemic has
caused this along with everything else
we've seen in the past couple of years
michelle joy howard is the founder of
floor couture she says during the
pandemic a lot of farms closed putting a
damper on product availability
they were bought out by big
conglomerates that only do flowers and
chains like your big box stores the
change that we've just seen is drastic
we're talking anywhere from 20 to 40
percent difference in the price of
flowers
next door howard's sister deborah newson
bavina is the owner of las vegas floral
and plant wholesale she tells me
inflation is hurting the industry and
driving prices out of control gas prices
are affecting the price of flowers the
cost of labor the cost of fertilizer yet
she refuses to let it stop her from
fulfilling orders and getting your
flowers in the hands of loved ones
overall we've been able to fulfill
95 percent of our orders there have been
a few shortages but
thank goodness our clientele has been
amazing because a single flower can have
a big impact on an emotional heart
whether it's self-care or you're trying
to give your emotions to somebody else
we love it and we love to make life blue
jeremy j ford live local now